hi this is pressure soccer and in this
video I'm going to perform a magic trick
for you the trick begins where you pick
out five different cards from the deck
and you would memorize their values at
this point I would emphasize that in a
normal trick you usually only need to
memorize the value and suit of one card
in this trick you're going to need to
memorize the valiant suit of five
different cards so it will require five
times as much concentration in this
video I need to show you that I'll be
able to reveal the cards so we'll just
say that the five different cards you
have are the Royal Flush of hearts which
are right here so going from ten of
hearts to the Ace of Hearts
so you memorize these five different
cards and while you've done that I place
the rest of the deck in five different
piles that are cards that are face down
and face up so we're going to take these
cards and we're going to mix them up and
place them one card on top of each pile
so the cards are spread out through the
deck some cards and we're going to mix
the piles up and any way that you like
since I have to perform this video for
you I'll just put the cards like that
furthermore we're going to take these
cards and mix them up even more so I'm
going to take a set of cards and either
place them face down or face up if I
were performing this for you live you
would be telling me whether to put it
face down or to flip it over so we'll go
through the entire deck and we'll play
some of them facedown and some of them
face up and to make sure the cards are
thoroughly mixed up we'll go ahead and
do that one more time so some cards will
go facedown some of the cards will get
flipped other ones will just continue to
be the same
flip these over keep these the same flip
these over flip these over and continue
throughout the deck flip these well do
one final process of randomization which
is the split the two two cards into two
different piles
now some of the cards will be facedown
and some of them will be face-up and
bear with me because it's going to take
a moment to go through the entire deck
but think about the decision which is
once I put all these cards down I want
you to flip over the cards of one of the
piles so you can either take the pile
over here and flip it over or we'll take
this pile and flip it over now we have a
deck with some cards that are face-up
and some cards that are facedown I want
you to tell me the first time that you
see one of your cards from the Royal
Flush of Hearts all right we still don't
see it
we'll keep going we're getting closer to
the end of the deck and we still have
not seen any cards from the Royal Flush
of Hearts so that must mean we have a
few cards that you're facedown and those
are your five cards I hope you liked
this video please subscribe to my
channel and watch the next video where I
explain the mechanics of how this works